one is this fellow who created this book
and his name is john clement
john duke lamont i think he's canadian
at least he's based in canada he speaks
like four languages he always translates
all his stuff in four languages
which is not bad you know and that's his
book there
one of his books the worldwide list of
alternative theories and critics
okay and he puts me in there and he says
this fluid ether the cart
is he kidding me is he really kidding me
and uh
what's the kind of particle that i
propose pair linked so yeah anyone who
just looks at this just touched that
little snapshot
says oh bill's just another dissident
who proposes some kind of particle you
know and some kind of ether
and some kind of uh you know and he
follows a cart and
who knows what that's the impression
people get for just by looking at that
well john de claremont he um wrote a
letter to me uh
some time ago he's asking me to look at
his video and that was that's the link
for his video
and i didn't look at it because i
already knew what he stood for in
general terms
and um just a couple days ago two three
days ago someone
puts that same video and copies me
saying oh look there's a new ether
and i said well i better look at this
because i'm dealing with ether here on
my channel so i might as well look and
see what the new vision is and you go in
there and use
under the video description it says the
video presents a new vision of the ether
and it's made possible the climates
experiment of course
right so i listen to the video and this
is what you see in there what you hear
in there particles of space
stir in all directions to form a kind of
fluid they are the medium
of the space the second is that they
propagate waves as in all fluids
and i said what in the world
this this is the new ether it looks to
me just
just like the old ether you know what
was the old ether a bunch of particles
that
you know it's vibrating that's the wave
that's in this case proposing exactly
the same thing
he's saying the ether in other words i
don't care what the ether does
that's not a new version of these i want
to know what the ether
is before anybody waves or moves it and
what is it it's a bunch of particles
so he hasn't told us what the ether is
what encapsulates each particle what's
outside of the ether
if anything or if the ether is infinite
those are the issues you got to deal
with first you can't just move on and
say
this is the ether let me show you what
it does now